when you see things in general
throughout mathematics and they're half
right there half you should start
thinking is there something symmetrical
about this situation
okay so case sorry approach number two
is arguing from symmetry now one of the
overarching principles that we mentioned
in approach one by cases is sometimes a
problem seems insurmountable because
just so large it's like if you have 50
letters and you arrange me like my brain
just hurts thinking about feet I can't
draw 50 letters right in the same way
over here with cases you're hoping
there's nine cases now that's not
impossible to do it's not impossible but
it's very time consuming you don't have
to do all my boat right so general
principle here is establish a pattern
establish a pattern and if you can see
logically why it should just go down one
every time then go ahead and take a body
in that path okay strategy number two
which hopefully you remember from year 7
in in problem solving is if your problem
is too large right think about a simpler
problem the grant a simpler problem and
see if you can borrow a pattern from
here that can go into your pattern which
has your spotter
okay so what you didn't notice thinking
back to the original question in the
condition you're given the letters D and
n are the important matters to us right
and the rest of them not that important
right so what I'm gonna do is just think
about those letters and think about if
they were less other letters to worry
about and if I can sort of take a pad
from here and take it
so what I'm going to do is I've actually
drawn up on your piece of paper right
I've drawn up a pair of um sets of boxes
I've drawn six because I happen to know
and you can verify this very easily with
me but that exactly six ways exactly six
ways that D can be before n or to the
left of him if you've got four minutes
to choose from okay so let's think about
this for example if I fix D in position
one right give me a place just one where
in can be it can be in position two
that's fine there's one of the wait okay
sticking with DBM in position one it's
not the only place it can go
it can go over into position 3 or it can
go over into position for right now -
remember I said to you at the beginning
we'll hear to you the probability and I
said if it's a small situation just miss
the damn things out
I can't just list them that's not don't
don't think less of listing things out
when he lists things out if you do it
systematically
you will see patterns with the
imposition one are there any other spots
that inka me it's a no so therefore I've
got a shift
Valente remark yeah ok so you can see
where this is going right where can it
be
either your position 3 or in position
four let's draw those oh there and then
you can see where the last one is ok now
these are all of the ways that n can be
to the right of team okay but you'll
notice I've given you six extra boxes on
the right hand side because these are
not all the ways that Dean and can be
positioned full staff these are only the
ones that meet our conditions okay what
would it mean
what's the converse or the complement of
whether of the condition we're looking
for what's the opposite yeah if you take
all of these guys and reverse them right
and reverse them so and this is what you
can fill in to your second set of boxes
if you want anybody and then D and and
then and then Dave right what you'll get
is an exact one-to-one correspondence
between the ones that meet the condition
and the ones that break a condition do
you see that so what you've got now what
you've got is you've got six over here
and then you've got six over here oh
okay now I happen to know I don't wonder
if you can work out why I happen to know
that once you've got these things and
you've got these six there are at least
two ways to argue I've got a lot of ways
that's it that's an exhaustive list okay
I don't want to give me a suggestion as
to how I know that these twelve vary
I have done first column right end is to
the right of D you've got your second
column it is through left of D okay and
I'm saying this is it there are no more
ways to place M or D in anywhere right
how do I know
okay so we can think about what's left
okay we can't think about what's left is
that well they have to occupy two
different spots so therefore if you have
a looked at if you try and list them out
you just not be able to come up with
more available spots it's more you think
about it and not super way though is
that in can be to the right of day and
can be to the left of T if you're not to
the right or to the left where else
could you possibly be this you you could
nmd be on the same spot I can't well not
if you're making a word right so
therefore I've exhausted all the options
have exhaustively options now there's
one more way I can think about this
which guarantees why it's twelve twelve
twelve happens to be for Pete shoot but
why should for Pete to be the number of
ways that I can do this
so there are four now now I'm shifting
now now I want you to imagine okay I've
got these two letters in my hand and
I've got four places where I can
position them and I have to pick two of
them does the order matter for the
twelve it does because it's because they
could be first or it could be first
right so therefore I am now thinking
about rather than like oh which letter
goes where I'm thinking about letters
and spots these are spots that I'm
picking from there are four of them and
on the order Madison so I've done for p2
for Peters twelve song done this is all
okay so now I have a way a reason to
argue right that this over here this is
not the only way to come up with
forty-five thousand three hundred and
sixty right another way is to say your
total ways
twelve you just have to hire them right
exactly half of them will beat the
condition you want right so I'm going to
write my cards are very differently
the total ways right is half all the
ways without restriction which you
already know do you see that so this is
actually 19 factorial on C factorial to
factor that's at ninety thousand number
and that normally gets divided by two
and that lands you one forty five
thousand three hundred and sixty okay so
I give you a symmetry that's a nice way
to go left or right left all right
you've only got two choices if you ever
see this left or right problem this is
one of the tools one of the principles
you can use